oui donc j'ai la version de la
production alors déjà il était au
courant apparemment parce qu'il ya des
défis qu'ils étaient lancés sur tik tok
donc des jeunes qui prévenait qui allait
avoir ses piqûres pendant la chanson de
l'année la sécurité les foules été
renforcées il y avait 120 personnes pour
treize mille personnes dans le public
cinq à dix personnes auraient été piqué
selon la production et le débat secure
et aucun produit dangereux injectés
selon la production donc des piqûres à
vide entre guillemets aucune hausse
mathis hospitalisations liées à ces
piqûres deux personnes interpellées et
il y aurait une seule personne blessée
c'était un des agents de sécurité
tentaient de maîtriser un des suspects
clavier d'installation mais bien
l'expression la même force personnes qui
ont déposé plainte pour les piqûres donc
le ils disent qu'il ya cinq à dix
personnes qui ont faim qui aurait été
piquée mais a quand même 14 personnes
qui sont allées au commissariat alors
sont d'abord déposer
n'estime qui aurait 60 personnes très
centaines de personnes piquées dont 14
qui seraient jusqu'à déposer plainte il
ya trois raisons il y en a eu 1 et
partie 2 grenoble 1-2 lyon ils viennent
de choper quelqu'un et puis maintenant à
raison dans le sud de la france ils se
lancent des défis à tik tok snapshot et
facebook élèves le problème c'est que
les enquêteurs sont submergés par les
défis que se lancent ces jeunes c'est je
vais à toulon tu y vas aussi on empile
50 jean ping 40 etc
c'est une folie en ce moment des jeunes
alors heureusement c'est vrai que à
priori ya rien branler seringue et les
préfectures on va avoir un effet de leur
qui a dit surtout aller dans ces cas-là
à l'hôpital tout de suite alors il y
avait la lira victime d'une piqûre qui
travaillent tous dans un instant et son
papa fred est pour l'instant bruno c'est
quoi alors c'est quoi cette histoire est
ce que dans le secteur médical on parle
de plus en plus de ces piqûres oui tout
à fait alors les premiers signaux en
france date de la fin de 2021 d'accord
en fait il y avait une épidémie de
piqûre au royaume uni à partir de 100
les anglais 21
il faut savoir une fois c'est pas c'est
pas un phénomène nouveau au en 1819 lors
de la restauration il y avait eu ce
phénomène
et c'était des piqûres avec des styles
et ça avait duré à peu près une saison
entière et puis ça avait disparu visiter
surveiller sont ici en bas piqué comme
ça montre simplement que c'est quelque
chose qui arrive effectivement donc ce
sont des personnes qui veulent instaurer
une peur dans la ville donc les piqûres
aux lieux essentiellement dans des
réunions il y a
le pascua évidemment on peut se
qualifier donc plutôt festif des
concerts de musique des festivals des
bars des boîtes de nuit émissions mais
aussi dans le métro dans le transport
dans la rue ça peut arriver
alors effectivement le milieu médical
est en alerte parce qu'en fait il ya une
urgence lorsque l'on est piquée affaire
a porté plainte d'accord et évidemment
pour éviter que ses fastes les traces
d'un éventuel produits qui auraient été
injectés en plus évidemment pour pouvoir
recevoir la prévention d'une éventuelle
infection contagieuse notamment les
hépatites virales
le
l'infection par le vih oh oui valérie
alors j'ai dit non parce que même si
effectivement il n'y a rien qui est
injectée puisque visiblement il
semblerait qu'il n'y ait rien le fait
que j'imagine ils vont pas changer la
seconde donc là il ya un facteur
aggravant face à dire qu'on peut
éventuellement rien à récupérer les avez
raison ça alors en fait je peux donner
quelques données descriptives des 350
premier cas qui ont été analysées trois
cent cinquante ans voilà alors il y en a
beaucoup plus trois cent cinquante
premiers cas donc déjà ça touche
essentiellement des jeunes femmes donc
66 % de filles la moyenne d'âge est de
20 ans alors dans un quart des cas
quelque chose d'important la personne
qui piquait ne seront pas comptés en
fait c'est secondaire mans qu'elle voit
la trace de la piqûre et va aller à
l'hôpital cinq ans lorsqu'elle se rend
compte qu'elle a d'emblée à l'hôpital
dans 60% des cas donc deux tiers des cas
la piqûre peut être vérifiée certifiée
par un personnel soignant
dans aussi à peu près deux tiers des cas
il y a des symptômes qui vont suivre
cette piqûre évidemment la figure est
déjà très traumatisante mais dans à peu
près deux tiers des cas il valoir des
symptômes alors essentiellement une
sensation de perte de connaissance de
fatigue de vertiges
il peut y avoir une tachycardie une
crise d'angoissé
il peut y avoir des troubles digestifs
en tout cas ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
toujours dans tous les cas qui ont été
analysées et ce sont des symptômes
bénins
spontanément réversible
le point important aussi c'est que
évidemment il faut absolument porter
plainte en premier d'accord plutôt que
d'aller directement aux urgences il faut
déjà acquis de regard porté plainte et
pourquoi parce que ça permet ensuite
d'aller aux urgences médico-judiciaires
déplacement là on va faire un examen
certifiée par un médecin légiste et un
bilan sanguin à l'endos psychologique
qui pourra ultérieurement et nous
reconnu par la justice donc ce sont des
points importants il faut faire ça très
rapidement pourquoi pas un certain
nombre de substances disparaissent
rapidement par exemple le ghb dont tout
le monde parle eh bien on peut le
détecter jusqu'à à peu près huit heures
dans le sens et 12h dans les urines
quand il faut aller relativement
rapidement et puis évidemment le médecin
va prescrire une un traitement de
prévention de l'infection contre le vih
comme vous l'avez dit si évidemment on a
été piquée en cinquième ou dixième
position et bien où il ya quand même un
risque malgré tout de transmission d'un
certain on n'aura rien fait qui n'est
pas un instant les arrivants dans un
instant que son papa voilà oui je
gardais oui doctors qui est étonnant
c'est que vous saviez comme disait la
production dit qu'il ya pas de produits
moi j'ai eu les policiers ils disent y'a
pas de produits mais vous vous nous
dites c'est très important il ya eu des
cas où effectivement on a retrouvé au
delà du fait piquer des produits
dangereux administré par ces seringue
alors non je ne dis pas ça je dis que
vous faites une enquête on est très
détaillé avec une analyse toxicologique
très poussée pour rechercher d'éventuels
substance alors la difficulté c'est
qu'évidemment souvent ces personnes ont
déjà consommé 2 par la fête dans sa
forme de sucre a notamment l'alcool donc
déjà les alcools et souvent retrouvé
ensuite évidemment il faut faire la part
des médicaments que prennent ces
personnes de part leur et manchons et
puis en plus des produits qu'elle aurait
éventuellement consommées soit
volontairement soit souvent c'est ça en
fait le cas
sans le savoir c'est ce qu'on appelle la
vulnérabilité chimiques c'est avec ce
sont des personnes qui ont été tentées
de l'autre sens qu'ils ne connaissent
pas mme professeurs se sont fragilisés
et les personnes qui piquent en fait
hors pair dans la foule des personnes un
peu plus frais sera d'accord voir agir
d'abord parce que vous dites qu'il
fallait d'abord porté plainte avant
d'aller aux urgences ya plein de gens
qui disent vous êtes donc
voilà on est on est plutôt tranquille
sur les sujets il n'y a pas de souci
voilà aujourd'hui dans les 350 cas
analysés en france mais n'y a aucune
substance dans les 1500 cas qui s'était
analysé royaume uni il ya eu trois cas
où on a identifié de la kétamine est un
ami de produits somnifères sédatifs de
l'aquitaine ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
le risque principal c'est d'avoir des
médicaments courants c'est à dire des
somnifères des antihistaminiques stade
de l'allergie parce qu'en fait les gens
vont utiliser des produits quand ils ont
à disposition c'est évidemment se
procurer une drogue de du ghb c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et donc c'est
peu probable a juste mis basharat quart
par rapport à la piqûre comme les piquer
dans les muscles le rythme que le
produit se diffusant un petit peu plus
fort s'il vous plaît c'est vous qui me
sentais pas bien aux 10,41 rien photo
benjamin ce que j'adore ça donc comme
comme somme c'est une piqûre qui va dans
le mur c'est dans la tête
la trame musculaire il va t'arriver le
produit si tout se passe donc dans le
sens directement donc pas dans les
veines vous n'êtes pas un risque réel
d'être empoisonné docteur il a rien
compris
et élections peut se faire par voie
cutanée pour avoir sous cutanée ou par
voie intramusculaire un peu partout le
cible principale qui a utilisé ses les
membres supérieurs mais ça peut être
dans les jambes dans les bruits de pas
de conséquences
il a compris
leur permet au produit quand même de
diffuser sida va directement dans le
sang il va être absorbée encore
d'ailleurs quand vous avez comme citoyen
quelconque et qu'on vous fait une piqûre
c'est pas nécessairement une piqûre une
injection intraveineuse c'est une
injection intra musculaire voir ce que
donnait à ce moment là le produit
diffusé certains jeux plus lentement de
père finit par diffusée sur deux est un
droit parce que vous arrivez à répondre
aux réactions que vous ne comprenez pas
et ça mais ça s'assume pas techniquement
juste avant d'accueillir les victimes
d'une piqûre qui va nous raconter ce qui
s'est passé samedi soir be flown ils ont
chanté leur nouveau titre aux siens
parce que si vous avez regardé les pics
ou je les embrasse d'ailleurs les deux
frérots j'espère qu'ils vont pouvoir
bientôt plus rien parce que leur nouvel
album très très très fort oui j'ai gardé
un truc kelly kelly tu vois je voulais
savoir si quelqu'un était au courant de
ce qu'ils encourraient pénalement s'est
jointe à mal c'est ça peut être conquis
sa vraie nature j'espère que c'est alors
voici nos chers alors tout jardinier
c'est une agression avec une amie a
sûrement il risque bien sûr la hat
ouvert une information officer qui a été
ouverte c'est pour violences aggravées
par arme et préméditation exactement il
faut quand même savoir que dans sur les
354 qui ont été analysées dans 3% dès
cas cette agression qui est en elle-même
déjà criminelle s'est suivie par un acte
de violence plus important ou une
tentative de viol ou de viols et 100
mais non dans des dans de très rares cas
donc en fait les gens font ça entre
guillemets gratuitement de façon un peu
ça disent qu'on a déjà eu des gens qui
ont été interrogés où on est sûr qu'ils
ont commis cet acteur 2 alors il ya des
interpellations après je ne suis pas au
courant de l'attaqué mais il ya une
personne a été interpellée là il ya une
station chez l'un d'entre eux qui a été
relâché parce qu'il n'est pas
suffisamment de preuves et l'autre qui
pourraient être condamnés auxquels je
n'aime rien tant il nie les faits mais
il était placé en détention provisoire
effectivement docteur sur les 350
personnes qu'on a étudié qui ont été
piqués ya aucun cas de dire d'aiguilhe
qui a été et qui ont été souillées par
une hépatite et tout ça il n'y a pas eu
de contamination avérée ou l'argent la
suite de ces deux de ces piqûres dans
les 350 cas analysés mais évidemment ça
reste un risque théorique accor est en
tout cas il faut prendre une prévention
c'est pourquoi il ya urgence à consulter
comme je les rênes mais également quand
même au cas où voilà d'accord c'est pour
ça que je les rappelle c'est d'abord
c'est bon c'est plein c'est à ce que
l'examen médical et les prélèvements
toxicologiques ou rondes seront faits
dans le cadre de la médecine légale et
donc auront une valeur devant le
tribunal oui j'ai des regrets après on
va accueillir les ja isle son père qui a
été victime d'une piqûre hui dr la
médecine c'est aussi de la prévention
alors c'est pas de notre responsabilité
mais là un des gros problèmes qui s'est
passé c'est que visiblement les
palpations était très déficiente et a
pas eu de vraie palpation et ce qu'il
faut maintenant pas à chaque fois qu'on
sort en boîte de nuit que des gens vous
fouilles et c'est parce que sinon on
peut entrer avec des seringues dans tous
les lieux festival mais alors vous avez
raison donc moi je suis pas expert de ce
bruit est par contre je dire il faut
être très vigilant nous d'abord ne pas
perdre son verre de l'oeil le lou va en
boîte de nuit restez avec un groupe
d'amis en fait c'est de la vigilance de
groupe s'appuie surtout évidemment et
bien ne pas se laisser daniel cousin et
que l'on connaît pas passer à nouveau le
grand risque ce qu'on appelle la
vulnérabilité chimiques c'est à dire de
consommer un produit que l'on connaît
pas exactement et à salade de perdre un
tout petit peu ses moyens d'ailleurs
dans 15% des cas où il y à cette piqûre
qui probablement ne comporte pas de
produit il ya une amnésie qui est
racontée sagres et personne ne se
souvient pas exactement mais constate
secondairement la présence de la
fiscalité qui c'est qui a raison parce
que j'aurai alors envers les segments
que merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
très délai alors les uns qui s'est fait
piquer la pauvre samedi soir elle était
la chanson de l'année et fred qui est ce
papa de l'oea qui lui vient en tant que
voilà papa inquiet alors les âmes achiri
merci d'être là en tout cas c'est que
vous avez couru grave ce qui est des
problèmes dans le train il ya eu un
bagage abandonné apparemment wells et je
connais l'ascension de tony c'est un
bagage à
aller alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
samedi soir dit notre bête toute allure
dans le micro wallisien maintenant c'est
bien on va très bien tout allait bien et
au final peu marche le métro l'a
commencé à me courir sur le haricot oui
alors là deux marches à l'heure et
marchait pas oui
vraiment pour un con
azilal et bien avec ma meilleure amie et
au final le belge j'ai rien senti
c'est qu'avec kinect serait connu une
dernière a mis d'accord et vous vous
appliquez dans le dos et dans la jambe
ah ouais deux piqûres ouais d'accord au
début vous avez rien senti un sentiment
quand vous avez comme vous êtes et
commence à s'engourdir ah oui oui
comment ça se fait ça commence à saissac
les
candidats alors cepsum ans et c'est pas
ses passes on va dire il ya l'effet
psychologique alors si je ne le savais
pas aussi la piqûre sur le moment non
vous l'avez constaté seconde herman
paris avait senti un engourdissement oui
c'est ça alors on va dire si la personne
a piqué dans la jambe au niveau d'un air
par exemple ça peut entraîner une sorte
de décharge ou un engourdissement de la
jambe d'accord après il ya toujours
l'effet psychologique évidemment
notamment de si on voit d'autres
personnes à côté de soi qui ont été
piqués de panique de peur d'angoissé
genre peut aussi somatisé un certain
nombre de pas d'inquiétude il ya donc là
vous c'est quoi comment vous avez su
vous avez été piqué alors commencé au
tout début je commence à avoir les gens
ils étaient
je voyais les personnes jeunes gens
tentaient de moins en moins et au final
beige et fait un malaise
j'ai été récupéré par les pompiers ils
me donnaient de l'eau est moins hydrater
et après ils m'ont mis sous et moi ils
m'ont fait aller sous la tente
et il y avait 50 minutes d'attentes ce
qui était énorme donc
j'ai ma meilleure amie elle a appelé mon
combat et
mais le temps qu'il arrive pas mon corps
il a lâché je ressentais plus mon corps
je faisais je n'avais plus les moyens je
pouvais plus marcher
ou alors il faut il faut savoir bourassa
lors on peut pas dire
très attention alors il parfois aussi on
peut suspecter des produits qui ne sont
pas des toxiques par exemple l'insuline
pour l objection d'insuline pour y faire
baisser le taux de sucre glace en lave
faire ressentir ce malaise
d'hypoglycémie c'est possible c'est
pourquoi en fait lorsque l'on va aller à
l'hôpital il faut faire des analyses
poussées pas que toxicologiques mais
aussi rechercher d'autres substances
plus naturelle plus difficile à dix cas
détectés mais que l'on peut tout à fait
rechercher si elles sont exogènes alors
en fred vous êtes papa lé là vous y
étiez aussi c'était comment cette soirée
alors dit que c'était infernal c'est à
dire c'est bon on a juste il faut parler
c'est juste une tranche à monter à
monter moi je veux venir la montée mois
vous allez voir ça va être tout
photographe donc en fin de compte ça
s'est passé que déjà dès le début
c'était déjà un manque d'organisation
les gens c'est comme si c'était vers
vous là au pire entre et l'imaginaire
l'a imaginé la foule rennes a qui sont
passés en dessous comme au stade de pré
saison il se peut passer en dessous des
anglais et aux angles de la sécurité
civile et on était devant pour entrer il
n'y a pas de barrière quand il ya trop
de monde est maintenant bien dans le
micro on met des barrières pour avancer
pour que les gens ils soient pas trop
d'accord quant à ckoi là il y avait rien
en fait c'était tout le monde est
entassé les handicapés ils pouvaient
même pas passé en fauteuil roulant rien
d'accord a fallu que et vous vous étiez
là bas alors vous n'avez pas été
appliquée bon non non mais partie avant
d'accord quand vous avez les deux filles
la compagnie ma deuxième petit et on est
parti quand vous avez appris que votre
fille s'était fait piquer vous êtes
inquiétez-vous abbaoui surtout que là là
toujours là jambes engourdies trt c'est
incroyable quand ses portes alors voilà
est-ce que ces salles pendant toujours
des nouvelles est ce que vous êtes allé
porter plainte très rapidement le sale
points importants donc il faut porter
plainte ensuite est-ce que vous êtes
allé voir un médecin légiste donc aux
urgences médico judiciaires
c'est elle qui pourra dire c'est pas moi
voilà oui ils m'ont interrogé
les policiers m'ont interrogé ils ont
pris ma plainte a dit à la presse j'ai
je suis passé à l'hôpital direct c'est
les pompiers qui sont venus me chercher
parce que mon cas je me sentais partir
voilà enfin bon j'ai ouï je pouvais plus
parler j'avais pas plus rien il vaut
mieux faire l'ordre inverse c'est à dire
porter plainte puis ensuite aller
et si ce n'est pas possible
un pas important ça peu importantes
concernant le type de prélèvement parce
que si les prélèvements sont faits par
un urgentiste non certifiés ça a moins
de valeur après annoncé les gendarmes
qui m'ont fait les prix les faits voilà
comme c'est fait par un médecin légiste
ou sur réquisition des forces de l'ordre
ou de l'officier de police judiciaire
qui ont là ça a une valeur qui va être
reconnue par le tribunal s'il ya une
plainte évident j'étais pas tout seul à
l'hôpital y avait plusieurs personnes
mais ces bois c'est important aussi
parce que nous faisons une formation de
l'ensemble des médecins urgentistes a
lentement pour savoir faire les choses
parce qu'un point important par exemple
c'est de ne pas donner un anxiolytique
la personne qui vient parce qu'après ça
pourrait fausser évidemment les
mécanismes n'ont rien donné mais
pourquoi pourquoi l'été pourquoi elle
est tombée dans les pommes et ya pas de
produire sa qui échoue bah c'est ce que
je dis c'est dégueulasse je ne peux pas
dire évidemment sur les analyses très
poussées pourront le dire alors il ya
toujours la place de l'injection d'un
produit comme la possibilité comme je
l'expliquais de l'injection par exemple
d'insuline qui provoque une chute de mme
avait de quoi mais c'est sucré donc
c'est un produit car quand même
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de dire parce que c'est vrai que
vous êtes un père de famille vous avez
emmené vos deux fils house est dit
j'étais allé un spectacle on était comme
des fous et puis c'est la soirée s'est
passée comme en cauchemar à sortir c'est
le problème les festivités l'été c'est
tout à l'air libre il va y avoir
d'autres problèmes
problème donc là ça vous fait flipper ou
dit ouais ouais je le vois je le vois je
te sens
je suis entre bah ouais je vais pas te
raconter l'histoire je te souviens-tu
concerts gratuits il y avait treize
mille personnes qui pouvaient aller et
venir librement plus de 3000 personnes
qui attendaient dehors donc là c'était
très compliqué on était famille voilà
autant les valaisans et ce qui est
paradoxal c'est que là ils sont poussés
les micros
[Applaudissements]
sipa les regards ces raisons ils n'y
croient pas ils sont en voyant ce qu'il
fait c'est que beaucoup de gens
s'accordent à dire qu'il n'y avait rien
dans ces seringue mais vous quand on
vous écoute on marche on est sûr de vous
êtes fait injecter un liquide toxique
c'est ça c'est quoi votre théorie
apprécié juste une piqûre c'est une
piqûre marais c'est toujours au loup
trop tard
vous poser une question inélégant est-ce
que par ailleurs vous avez vu où vous
avez pris nca tu te sens pas parce que
les unités tout à l'heure elle doit pas
s'arrêter parce que le docteur disais
tout à l'heure il y avait aussi pas mal
de jeunes parce que mon sexe que ces
fiches
le manque d'eau tout ça je veux bien
mais le soir
oui dernière question du monde sait que
ce sont des défis des build entre jeunes
je revis oui je crois qu'il serait
intéressant que les jeunes entrent se
dénonce ou 10 parce qu'à chaque fois
maintenant c'est tous les soirs il n'y a
pas que dans cette soirée c'est partout
c'est arrivé de 5n aussi tout ça arrive
tout le temps et ça va arriver dans la
vie de plus en plus c'est quoi je suis
d'accord il est par contre je crois que
commencer par dont je termine si tu es
au calme toi si tu sur les réseaux
sociaux je crois qu'il faut le dire dès
que ça sort de prévenir la police
effectivement ça n'était pas ce que dit
le médecin sérieux où tu étais sur rfm
avec eddy mitchell merci les a pas été
pris au sérieux il n'a calé poster des
choses sur beaucoup sur lui ouais bah je
suis pas vu la connerie
[Musique]
pareille au chocolat quand je dis non
mais paris comme j'ai dit à une personne
qui s'est fait piquer nom et qu'elle est
revenue le vendredi c'est vrai vous
habituer commission n'était pas un gars
qui voulait faire ces vaccins c'est ce
que j'ai pensé aussi simple concept de
jun n'y a pas une pique à la magnifique
mais giuly incroyable contre bobby mais
c'est fermé ces fermes et ben voila
merci en tout cas merci d'être